The problem we have is that the damage
we coast to the global environment is
not reflected in the price of the energy
we consume.
Right?
That's the most basic definition of the
problem.
We,
we,
we have.
If you bring even partly the,
the,
the cost,
the what we call the external cost of
your fuel consumption into the price of
energy you raised,
your price is a bit higher or much
higher if you do it.
If you do it a meaningful.
There's no way around that.
Yes.
Addressing climate change is all about
changing the relative prices of energy
to make the carbon intensive ones
relatedley more expensive and the carbon
less intensive one relatively less
expensive.
Actually.
It's all about what the public will
believe and what they will take in the
way of messaging.
Whatever they want.
A ton of ton of a democracy.
It actually matters.
Well,
they did.
That wasn't.
That wasn't the point that we are.
It was Mike,
Mike Stevens,
who pointed out that it was a real
problem with the public
believed and what the power of those who
have got all authority of the eloquence
in order to convey the right message.
The saving the world message of alcohol
was absolutely hopeless.
It is not convincing anybody at all.